kampf gegen die korona epidemie
bundeskanzlerin merkel kündigt eine
weitgehende stilllegung des öffentlichen
lebens an und wirbt um verständnis
weniger co2 in der luft deutschland hat
2009 10 weniger klimaschädliche
treibhausgase ausgestoßen
geheizt und gefahren wurde aber mehr
längere zwangspause für profis und fans
die deutsche fußball liga sagt alle erst
und zweitligaspiele bis mindestens
zweiter ab
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend will kommt man
diesem montag mit nachrichten in
schwierigen zeiten die korona krise
konfrontiert uns alle mit völlig neuen
lebensbedingungen
darauf hat uns soeben auch die
bundeskanzlerin eingestimmt vor einer
stunde sagte sie der presse die
bundesregierung empfehle den ländern nun
auch die meisten geschäfte zu schließen
ausgenommen die lebenswichtigen auch in
kirchen moscheen und synagogen sollen
menschen vorläufig nicht mehr
zusammenkommen
klaus brodbeck es geht immer weiter was
bereits einzelne bundesländer für sich
entschieden hatten gilt jetzt für ganz
deutschland
das sind maßnahmen dieses in unserem
lande so noch nicht gegeben hat die
natürlich einschneidend sind aber sie
sind im augenblick notwendig um die
anzahl der kontakte zu reduzieren und
damit auch die zahl der erkrankungen und
damit auch die zahl der schweren
erkrankungen bars und clubs müssen zu
machen
auch museen und theater kinos und
opernhäuser sportstätten aller art
kinderspielplätze dürfen nicht mehr
benutzt werden
aber bei weitem nicht alles wird
dichtgemacht nicht geschlossen ich
beginne jetzt einfach mal damit wird der
einzige an die für lebensmittel werden
die wochenmärkte abhol und lieferdienste
getränkemärkte die apotheken
sanitätshäuser drogerien tankstellen
banken und sparkassen poststellen
friseure reinigungen waschsalons und
auch zeitungsverkäufer auch bau- und
gartenmärkte sowie der gesamte
großhandel sollen offen bleiben die
einhaltung der verbote wird kontrolliert
auch durch polizei wir haben gemerkt
dass in der tat der appell und die
warnung alleine nicht ausreicht die
menschen davon abzuhalten viele
unterschätzen immer noch die gefahren
viele verharmlosen dass viele aus
naivität aber leider eben auch in
sozialen netzwerken aus böswilligkeit
auch der bundespräsident ruft am
nachmittag dazu auf die regelungen zu
befolgen
haben sie verständnis für alle
einschränkenden maßnahmen
sie sind notwendig bitte halten sie sich
daran die weniger wir einander begegnen
desto besser die chancen corona in den
griff zu bekommen
der kampf hat erst begonnen ja das gab
es tatsächlich noch nie solche
einschränkungen im öffentlichen leben
theo theo koll was davon zu halten
nun werde ich zu sein es ist eine art
gesellschaftliche vollbremsung zumindest
werden wir aus dem vierten oder fünften
gang in den ersten zurückgeschaltet die
lebenswichtigen dinge werden zwar noch
garantiert und offen gehalten
lebensmittel gesundheitsversorgung und
ähnliches fans gerade gehört aber
jenseits dessen soll das
gesellschaftliche leben zu einem
weitgehenden stillstand kommen das ziel
ist klar
jetzt soll schnell und tief in das
soziale miteinander eingeschnitten
werden weil jeder weitere mit
menschliche kontakt eine art sprungbrett
für die viren sein kann die politik
versucht im allerletzten moment durch
diese drastischen maßnahmen die zahl der
erkrankung zu begrenzen denn man muss
schon sagen
der bisherige ansatz keine panik zu
schüren und eher entspannter auf sicht
zu fahren
der hat sich als trügerisch erwiesen das
ganze ist ausdrücklich keine
ausgangssperre aber dann doch der viel
entscheidendere versucht diesen virus
viele seine übertragungsmöglichkeiten
zudem wir hören aus dem kanzleramt
übrigens dass man sich binnen zwei
wochen erfolge erhofft ja sie sogar
erwartet danke für die einordnung tier
in deutschland haben sich laut johns
hopkins institut knapp 6700 menschen
infiziert 14 menschen sind gestorben
bayern hat heute als erstes bundesland
zu drastischen maßnahmen gegriffen und
den katastrophenfall festgestellt
das klingt zunächst einmal heftig ist
aber weniger spektakulär als der name
vermuten lässt
im klartext bayerns ministerpräsident
söder verschafft seiner regierung die
möglichkeit quasi zum durchregieren
behörden und organisationen werden
zentrale gesteuert anweisungen können
direkt auseinander regierung kommen
alexander pohl hat die einzelheiten
es ist nicht das erste mal dass bayern
den katastrophenfall festgestellt und
doch ist heute vieles anders
eine pressekonferenz vor leeren reihen
besorgte gesichter der katastrophenfall
eine scharfe waffe im kampf gegen das
virus
der vorteil ist umfangreiche
möglichkeiten für die behörden klare
steuerung eingriffs und
durchgriffsmöglichkeiten alles muss in
eine richtung laufen in einer
gemeinsamen koordinierten form der
staatsregierung obliegt damit die
führung aller einsatzkräfte
sie ist von nun an etwa gegenüber der
feuerwehr hilfsorganisationen oder auch
dienstleistern weisungsbefugt dass die
zum beispiel die abwehr von gefahren für
medizinische dienstleistungen für das
was wir für reed erhalten durchgesetzt
wirken können durchgesetzt hat die
staatsregierung heute ein öffnungs
verbot für viele geschäfte darunter auch
buchläden
für sabine günther und ihre buchhandlung
in kirchheim bei münchen ist das keine
gute nachricht wir bleiben auf unseren
fixkosten miete et cetera hängen jeder
monat muss bezahlt werden und uns fehlt
einfach das geld
harte einschnitte kommen gerade auf
kleine und mittelständische betriebe zu
für sie stellt bayern hilfsmittel in
höhe von zehn milliarden euro bereit
whatever it takes ist ein satz den viele
aus der euro-krise kennen
der gilt auch für deutschland und vor
allem für bayern die heute beschlossenen
maßnahmen bleiben für mindestens 14 tage
in kraft allerdings macht der bayerische
ministerpräsident klar dass die lage
jeden tag neu bewertet werden muss
auch für familien stellt das virus eine
enorme herausforderung dar
zehntausende schulen sind seit heute
geschlossen vorläufig bis zum ende der
osterferien und dasselbe gilt nach der
empfehlung der bundesregierung auch für
kitas und spielplätze
was heißt das nun für 15 millionen
schüler und kitakinder und was bedeutet
dass wir die eltern david sauer hat sich
bei ihnen um gehört millionen kinder
haben vorerst keine schule mehr und
deren eltern dadurch einen
betreuungsproblem seit heute mittag auch
in erfurt mandy hob schlag holt ihre
tochter zum vorerst letzten mal von der
schule ab
ich bin ja alleinerziehend voll
berufstätig und ich habe jetzt erstmal
meinen jahresurlaub genommen bis eine
andere lösung gefunden ist
job und kinder unter einen hut bekommen
auch in münchen jetzt noch schwerer als
sonst
wir müssen beide arbeiten weiter haben
zwei kinder zu hause haben da ein
kinderzimmer zum spielen münsterhausen
jetzt fünf wochen lang ich habe angst
davor her
bundesweit bieten kitas notbetreuung an
bevorzugt für eltern in sogenannten
systemrelevanten berufen etwa ärztinnen
und pfleger der betriebskita der uni
klinik in bonn
für die kleinsten kommt der frühling da
gerade rechtzeitig aber bei vielen
älteren schülern stehen bald wichtige
prüfungen an weiterführende schulen wie
hier in wiesbaden organisieren den
unterricht für die zeit zu hause weil
manche haben wir blätter bekommen quasi
und arbeitsaufträge und manche bekommen
wir halt digital per mail geschickt die
digitalisierung der bildung dieser tage
vielleicht noch wichtiger und präsenter
denn je
in der tat ist jetzt der druck da dass
wir das auch alles jetzt so machen dass
man darauf hinweist dass auf youtube
bestimmte lern filmchen laufen aber auch
wie man aufgaben mit den schülern weiter
gibt und dass die schülerinnen und
schüler auch rückmeldung geben müssen
einige schulbuchverlage stellen dafür
für die dauer der schließungen ihre
digitalen inhalte kostenlos zur
verfügung während die kinder zuhause für
die nächste prüfung lernen können die
eltern dann im home office arbeiten
die auswirkungen der krise sind auch an
mehreren deutschen grenzen zu spüren
seit dem morgen wird dort umfassend
kontrolliert betroffen sind die grenzen
zu luxemburg frankreich der schweiz
österreich und dänemark
aus diesen ländern kommt nahezu keiner
mehr nach deutschland rein darf nur noch
wer hier arbeitet oder waren bringt
senkt das berichtet die grenze in kehl
in baden württemberg geduldsprobe schon
am morgen für alle die aus frankreich
nach deutschland wollen viele pendler
sind hier unterwegs wartezeiten an der
grenze bis zu zwei stunden
es ist gleich in diesem zu spät aber es
ist gut man muss jetzt anfangen und die
leute mitmachen
die grenze überqueren darf nur noch wer
einen triftigen grund vorweisen kann
auch der warentransport geht weiter und
natürlich gerade pendler vom
berufsverkehr werden natürlich
befragungen durchgeführt wo arbeitet sie
personen wie man sich der jetzt hat hier
in deutschland arbeitet das ist halt
wäre es gut wenn er eine bescheinigung
von seinem arbeitgeber mit führt auch
bei flensburg an der deutsch dänischen
grenze kontrollen des
bundesgrenzschutzes seit heute morgen 8
uhr güterverkehr und pendler dürfen auch
hier weiter rein nach deutschland zum
einkaufen ein oder ausreißen das geht
nicht mehr
das findet jetzt bis auf weiteres nicht
mehr statt
wie hier in kiefersfelden sind auch die
grenzen von bayern nach österreich
betroffen
die bundespolizei kontrolliert in bayern
alle großen und mittelgroßen
grenzübergängen am bahnhof in
kiefersfelden fährt kein personenzug
mehr von und nach österreich
der bahnverkehr über die grenze komplett
eingestellt nicht nur grenzen werden in
diesen zeiten wieder hochgezogen es
scheint auch jedes land wieder nur für
sich selbst zu planen und zu entscheiden
das war eigentlich nicht so gedacht
wofür haben wir schließlich die
europäische union die meldet sich heute
in gestalt von kommissionspräsidentin
von der leyen
und schlägt einen vorläufigen einreise
stopp für nicht eu bürger vor damit dass
corona virus möglichst draußen bleibt
anne gellinek brüssels europaviertel ist
leergefegt wer kann arbeitet von zu
hause alle anderen hetzen von einem
krisentreffen zum nächsten morgen sitzen
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen rats präsident michael und die
chefin der europäischen zentralbank
zusammen mit mindestabstand nachmittags
folgt eine telefonkonferenz der eu
finanzminister
danach eine der g7 der großen 7
industriestaaten thema bei allen wie
kann die wirtschaft gestützt und vor
allem das virus eingedämmt werden
ein 30 tägiger einreise stopp in die eu
soll helfen die übertragung zu
verringern ich habe gerade die g7 staats
und regierungschefs informiert dass alle
reisen in die europäische union die
nicht zwingend notwendig sind
eingeschränkt werden ausgenommen sind
pendler und zurückkehrende eu bürger
schon morgen sollen die staats und
regierungschefs diesen vorschlag bei
einem telefon geschlossen sorge nummer
zwei der eu binnenmarkt schon jetzt
stauen sich lastwagen wie hier an der
tschechisch deutschen grenze die eu
kommission versucht das chaos zu
vereinheitlichen grenzkontrollen seien
im prinzip schon möglich müssten aber
medizinisch begründet sein
außerdem sollten an den grenzen sonder
spuren für lkw frei gehalten werden
die vorschläge der eu kommission kommen
spät und sie versuchen zu ordnen was
nicht mehr zuordnen ist die
eu-mitgliedsländer schotten sich
voneinander ab jeder ist sich selbst der
nächste
die rolle der eu kommission ist auf
bitten und vorschlagen begrenzt genau so
haben die mitgliedstaaten das bei der
gründung der eu gewollt noch sind für
eu-bürger reisen ins ausland möglich
ratsam sind sie nicht sagt nun auch
außenminister maß und warnt das risiko
wegen zunehmender einschränkungen nicht
die rückreise antreten zu können sei
hoch und genau das es tausenden
deutschen bereits passiert dominik
löschmeister berichtet wo sich sonst
touristen drängeln ist nur wenig los
flughafen palma de mallorca
heute nachmittag seit gestern gilt in
spanien eine ausgangssperre
die urlauber wollen nur noch zurück die
haben den flug bekommen wir sind so
glücklich wir waren nämlich wirklich ja
aber trotzdem wir sind so fast in tränen
ausgebrochen
wir haben es auch tatsächlich erst
gestern hier erfahren dass unser flug
für donnerstag gestrichen wurde und
dachte man es aber einfach wir wollen
jetzt doch schon eher nach hause und
haben jetzt glück gehabt mit 15
sonderflügen will die lufthansa etwa
4000 urlauber zurück nach deutschland
holen darunter touristen aus der karibik
oder von den kanaren auch condor setzt
sondermaschinen ein
jetzt geht es nicht mehr um
wirtschaftliche fragen sondern um die
verantwortung die fluggesellschaften als
teil der kritischen infrastruktur in
ihren heimatländern tragen betont
lufthansa chef carsten spohr bei der
lufthansa soll nur noch jede zehnte
fernverbindung stattfinden
tui sagt bis auf weiteres alle
pauschalreisen und kreuzfahrten ab der
reisekonzern will beim bund staatshilfen
beantragen und urlauber zurück nach
deutschland bringen
einige konnten wir hier in düsseldorf
erst gar nicht fliegen
nicht nur ägypten auch andere länder
lassen internationale flüge nicht mehr
rein keine urlauber mehr
mallorca wird schon jetzt wie
ausgestorben infolge der krise fällt
auch der deutsche aktienindex weiter
der dax stürzt unter die marke von 9000
punkten und damit auf den tiefsten stand
seit vier jahren
valerie haller an der frankfurter börse
geht das so weiter oder ist noch ein
ende in sicht
also solange die hiobsbotschaften noch
über den ticker laufen ist erstmal keine
nachhaltige erholung in sicht auch heute
wieder tatsächlich hohe verluste sogar
mehr als zehn prozent zwischendurch
notenbanken rund um den globus haben die
zinsen gesenkt geldspritzen gestartet
die finanzmärkte hat das aber noch mehr
in alarmstimmung versetzt auch
euro/dollar öl sogar gold geben kräftig
nach der absturz zeigt was die anleger
in den kommenden wochen erwarten nichts
gutes alle papiere tief in - einige
davon zweistellig der dax verliert über
fünf prozent damit hat er seit seinem
hoch mitte februar fast schon 40 prozent
seines wertes verloren
die krise greift auf immer mehr branchen
über der opel mutterkonzern psa schließt
seine europäischen werke bis ende märz
darunter auch die deutschen opel-werke
grund seien probleme bei zulieferern und
starke absatzrückgänge danke valerie
nach frankfurt an die börse
das weltweite thema nummer eins in den
usa könnte es auch wahlentscheidend sein
wer hat das beste konzept in der korona
krise darum wetteifern die kandidaten
der demokraten und werfen präsident
trump vor kein konzept zu haben
auch nicht gegen us börsenkurse im
sinkflug
elmar theveßen dicht zusammenstehen
eigentlich nicht gut aber gut schien die
nachricht über die sich donald trump
gestern freuen konnte die notenbank
senkt die zinsen auf fast null prozent
die märkte sollten begeistert sein wir
sind das stärkste land der welt
finanziell und überhaupt
trotzdem kurz nach der eröffnungsglocke
heute stürzten die kurse an der börse
zeitweise um zehn prozent fehlende
führungskraft im weißen haus das wird
zum wahlkampfthema in zeiten von corona
der präsident schade dem land weil er
die glaubwürdigkeit der wissenschaftler
untergrabe das alexa herumknabbern ohne
fakten ist nicht akzeptabel er verwirrt
die öffentlichkeit seien das empfiehlt
die krankenversicherung für alle die
helfen nicht mein beiden der kampf gegen
korona müsse komplett aus dem
bundeshaushalt bezahlt werden das ist
wie im krieg im krieg tut man was immer
man tun muss für seine leute unter e
mails präsidenten werde alles notwendige
in der krise kosten so sei mit b free
von den tests für alle bis zur
versorgung der erkrankte angesichts der
steigenden zahlen fordern auch die
bundesstaaten von ihrem präsidenten
klare ansagen stadt gemischte signale
trump solle die streitkräfte
mobilisieren um lazarette zu errichten
und die versorgung der bevölkerung zu
sichern
in einem krieg brauche man das militär
das ist ein krieg gegen das corona virus
einige bundesstaaten greifen selbst
durch es wird leer in cafés und
restaurants menschenansammlungen über 50
personen sind verboten über alle neuen
entwicklungen zur krone halten wir sie
auch online auf dem laufenden unter
heute.de in einem live blog und in einem
zdf spezial direkt nach diesen heute
-nachrichten anderes thema und das macht
mut
im vergangenen jahr ist der ausstoß von
treibhausgasen in deutschland deutlich
zurückgegangen
nach der vorläufigen bilanz des
umweltbundesamtes wurden im vergleich zu
2008 10
rund 54 millionen tonnen co2 eingespart
ein rückgang von 6,3 prozent
das erleichtert ist auch der
bundesregierung ihr einsparungsziel bis
ende 2020 zu erreichen
patricia biedermeier auch für politiker
und journalisten gilt in diesen zeiten
kein handschlag zur begrüßung nicht
dicht nebeneinander sitzen
ungewohnte bilder in der
bundespressekonferenz und es gibt auch
noch andere themen auch die klimakrise
bleibt wichtig sie ist bedrohlich sie
geht nicht einfach weg auch nicht in
corona zeiten die co2 emissionen sind im
letzten jahr deutlicher als erwartet
zurückgegangen
das ziel eine reduktion um 40 prozent
bis ende 2020 sei wieder in reichweite
zu verdanken ist der rückgang vor allem
dem ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
beim strom werden inzwischen über 40
prozent dadurch gedeckt doch derzeit
stockt der weitere ausbau die koalition
streitet unter anderem über
abstandsregelungen von windrädern diese
blockade
die müssen wir jetzt dringend aufheben
der ausbau von wind von sonnenenergie
muss dringend weiter gehen erhebliche
defizite gibt es im gebäude und vor
allem im verkehrsbereich immer mehr und
immer schwerere autos werden zugelassen
ein tempolimit auf autobahnen fordert
daher das umweltbundesamt wenn wir auf
120 kilometer pro stunde reduzieren
würden hätten sich eine einsparung von
2,6 millionen tonnen pro jahr
auch die grünen verlangen dass vor allem
im verkehrsbereich rascher und
konsequenter gehandelt wird
es gibt leider keinen grund zur
entwarnung bei der klimakrise
denn im verkehrsbereich haben wir das
problem sogar dass die co2 emissionen
noch steigen
co2 einsparungen wird es wohl in diesem
jahr geben zum teil bedingt durch corona
dies sei aber nicht von dauer mahnte die
umweltministerin
auch den sport hat das corona virus
eingeholt deshalb gibt es auch an meiner
seite hier vorübergehend keine kollegen
aus der sportredaktion 1 gibt es aber
heute zu berichten eine entscheidung vom
fußball und auch die hängt natürlich mit
der pandemie zusammen die bundesliga und
die zweite liga setzten ihre spiele bis
zum zweiten april aus mindestens marc
windgassen lange wurde diskutiert auf
der suche nach der idealen lösung die
liga geht in die verfrühte frühlings
pause bewährt sind anfang april die
situation neu auch wenn jetzt schon klar
scheint dass der spielbetrieb länger
ruhen wird als geplant
ich möchte ausdrücklich betonen dass das
nicht heißt dass wir stand heute davon
ausgehen
ab dem dritten april wieder zu spielen
alles ist also abhängig von der
aktuellen entwicklung optionen gibt es
viele ob sie allerdings durchführbar
sind das ist offen
der profifußball kämpft um das überleben
nicht unbedingt die reichen für eine
bayern dortmund oder leipzig doch aber
einige andere auch aus der ersten liga
daher will die dfl versuchen die saison
und den spielbetrieb irgendwie zu retten
zur not auch mit geisterspielen keine
unbedingt sympathisch aber wohl doch
eine notwendige entscheidung die eine
lösung für die größte krise des
deutschen fußballs gibt es also nicht
zumal die dfl am topf der uefa hängt
eine wie auch immer geartete fortführung
der saison unter umständen auch über das
normale saisonende hinaus hängt unter
anderem auch morgen an den
entscheidungen der uefa es geht um die
verschiebung der europameisterschaft
nach zdf-informationen aber durch die
uefa und ihren chef alexander schiff
ferien bereits beschlossen
das würde den nationalen ligen zeit
verschaffen die saison doch noch zu ende
zu bringen wenn er auch wie zuletzt ohne
publikum und sollte das nicht gelingen
geht es bei einigen profiklubs um das
wirtschaftliche überleben
zum schluss schauen wir in das herz
italiens nach rom wo sonst der verkehr
tobt und sich tausende durch die gassen
schieben herrscht zurzeit gespenstische
leere aber nicht immer und nicht überall
der papst hat die hohe genutzt für einen
spaziergang durch die ewige stadt
und er hatte ein ziel die kirche san
marcello all korso blumen auf den altar
und dann ein langes gebiet für die
vielen kranken für die vielen helfer und
für ein schnelles ende der pandemie
bleibt noch das wetter das wird wieder
trüb mit etwas regen in der mitte und im
süden zu den einzelheiten gleich gunther
tiersch so viel von uns für heute
marietta slomka bringt sie um 21 uhr 45
auf den neuesten stand
danke für ihr interesse und bleiben sie
gesund bis morgens
[Musik]
gute zuschauer wenigstens das wetter ist
schön in diesen zeiten aber es wird
morgen wieder nicht so sonnig sein wie
heute von frankreich ziehen dichte
wolken auf die werden vor allen dingen
über die mitte und den süden
hinwegziehen mit etwas regen und in
norddeutschland wird es dann morgen
nachmittag wieder stärker bewölkt heute
nacht zieht der regen auch von nordrhein
westfalen erreicht morgen früh auch
sachsen in der mitte deutschlands kalt
wird es im nordosten lüneburger heide
da kann es leichten frost geben genauso
wie im südöstlichen bayern und morgen
haben wir immer noch den regen in der
mitte so vom main bis nach sachsen
bayern sonst aber in norddeutschland
beginnt der tag doch relativ freundlich
mit sonne und wolken und einem starken
südwestwind und zum nachmittag hin da
wird es dann auch stärker bewölkt in
schleswig holstein im münsterland etwa
und ansonsten lockert im westen hier auf
während der regen so langsam aus
deutschland gegen die alpen zieht ja bei
den temperaturen es ändert sich wenig
zehn grad sind an den küsten sonst 13
bis 20 grad hier am oberrhein und es
bleibt auch noch am mittwoch so warm und
sonnig fast überall aber ab donnerstag
wird es von norden kühler und deutlich
wechselhafter
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut